hot breath what tips do you have for
anyone who
takes a storytelling approach to comedy
i i mean i mean for practice try to make
something boring interesting
you know and i just see you like
you gotta go mow the lawn all right
start start writing down details about
mowing the lawn see if you can make that
into a joke you can do that then you
know you could take any situation
tell a story about it again it doesn't
have to be the outcome of the the
physical
outcome of what happened in the story
you know it doesn't have to be an epic
tale it could be just something
pathetic and mundane and that's what's
interesting about it
and what do you this can kind of tag on
brody blair's question but his is pretty
much like when um
how do you write when you feel like
nothing is happening in your life how do
you find
motivation to write i don't
i mean i don't like force it some people
can go and sit
and write jokes and i don't
i can't do that i mean if nothing's
happened in my life i try to make my
life more interesting i'd try to do
i mean i'm not like an exercise guy like
bike ride but just anything like
get the blood flow and get like feel
like
mental health mental and physical health
uh
plays a lot into
for me to do comedy yeah me too like if
i'm
you know i don't write you know i might
write about being bummed out but i only
find things that i can make things
entertaining when i'm in a good mood if
i'm bummed out i'm not really
in the mood to create comedy i'll write
down details while i'm bummed out and
then maybe later it'll turn but